هذا هو أداء Tesla Model 3
بسعر يبدأ من 64000 دولار ، وهو
ما يقرب من ضعف سعر
طراز Tesla للمبتدئين 3 لهذا السعر ،
تحصل على هاتفين كهربائيين و 450
حصانًا ، لذا نعم هذا ليس سوى
مستوى الدخول ، وهنا الشيء في هذه
الأسعار تسلا بقوة في منطقة السيارات الفاخرة
هنا تتعارض مع علامات تجارية
مثل مرسيدس-بنز أوتتي بي إم دبليو
والتي قالت جميعها إنها ستخرج
بسيارات كهربائية خلال السنوات القليلة المقبلة
، سيتعين على أداء الطراز 3
التنافس على مزاياها و  هناك الكثير من
التسارع المذهل من 0 إلى 60 في 3.5
ثانية ، تقنية الطيار الآلي الرائعة وأسلوب التكنولوجيا الفائقة النظيف
، شيء واحد أشعر أنه
يمكن استخدامه ، هناك القليل من
التحسين الذي أشعر به عند هذا السعر ،
يجب أن تكون السيارة الفاخرة قادرة على التعامل مع عثرة
أفضل قليلاً من هذا ، فهذه
السيارة التي أقودها بها خيارات تبلغ قيمتها حوالي 10000 دولار ،
كما تقدم Tesla حزمة ترقية
أفضل للعجلات والإطارات
والمكابح بخمسة آلاف دولار ، وهي
ضرورية بدونها  إنها ليست
سيارة عالية الأداء حقًا ، إنها مجرد سيارة سريعة
بهذا السعر ، وهذا لا يكفي ميزة رئيسية
في Tesla Model 3 هي هذه
الشاشة المركزية الهائلة التي
تتحكم إلى حد كبير وتعرض لك كل شيء كشاشة
عرض معلومات ، إنه لأمر رائع
أن يعمل عداد السرعة هنا  على ما يرام تمامًا
مثلما تحب تشغيل المساحات التي
تصبح مزعجة قليلاً في النهاية ، فإن
أداء Tesla Model 3 يقترب من
أن يكون يستحق سعره المرتفع إلى حد
ما ، ولكن سرعان ما سيتعين عليه التنافس
ضد EVs من اللاعبين الكبار
وهم  سأحضر لعبتهم